only et is with Travel Channel's zak
bagans inside is haunted Museum again
and I don't know why
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so this is the room with the
devil's rocking chair now this is an
artifact that witnessed an exorcism with
Ed and Lorraine Warren now ed and
Lorraine Warren they did many different
cases but this particular case had to do
with David Glassell which is right over
there
hold on why are you walking back there
cuz we got to get close to the chair
come on let's go do you got to get close
to the chair Zach come on man and I'm
gonna tell you this chair it absorbed
the energy of those events
okay okay you gotta remember that this
isn't the chair okay but when you have
an object like this that witnesses a
moment like this an event a biblical
moment that has to do with real life
demons yeah it absorbs the energy from
that event and so this Devils rocking
chair had a lot to do with this guy this
is little David glass like David
Glassell was possessed by a demon and
Lorraine Warren responded to this case
they tried helping out and during the
exorcism this little boy was being
assisted by this guy Arnie Johnson Arnie
Johnson was David's sister's boyfriend
Barney Johnson was looking at him like
come on demon come on leave him alone
possess me you coward he was provoking
the demon the demon left David possessed
Arnie Johnson Arnie Johnson then
committed a murder this was the very
first time where the defense used
demonic possession as an excuse of why
their client committed murder now the
chair is behind this door this chair the
devil's rocking chair during these
exorcisms only Lorraine Warren and David
glass all right would physically see the
Beast sitting in the chair and in this
book here the devil in Connecticut this
is all true accounts this lists all the
mentions of The Devil's rocking chair
during
whole case okay so let's explain to
everyone
this was in the Peron House in brodo the
heron family that's they for a case that
was in 1973 this was later in 1980 this
is going to be inspiring the conjuring
three coming out in 2020 okay so and
it's weird that I'm all connected right
all these cases all of a sudden where ed
and Lorraine Warren left off the day
that I bought the devil's rocking chair
Lorraine Warren died now it's that's a
coincidence that's crazy that's weird
did when you when you buy these things
like the devil's rocking chair how who
tells you about them and how do you
transport it safely they're very hard to
find but people now know through videos
like this the museum and I collect these
things yeah now the guy that I had go
pick up the devil's rocking chair he's
been working for me forever he works on
my security and as he was delivering it
it's the very first time he's picked up
everything in this museum he had
nightmares for several nights after
picking up this chair now David Glatt
CIL's brother Jorge wrote a notarized
letter because he kept the chair in his
family he signed it notarized it and he
said that this chair during those
exorcisms was seen levitating it would
disappear and reappear it would rock
violently back and forth but he said
that anybody that has ever tried to sit
in the devil's rocking chair had severe
back problems now one of his friends is
still having trouble walking today and
had to have sit down you are going to
sit in this chair for the special if I
own this stuff I don't own it
just for people to come look at it
because it's a cool museum this is my
life
they took to witness the hours why are
you going to sit in the chair Zak
because I want to see if it's if it's
real I want to see if
me back prop you know so I'm gonna give
it a try
[Music]
this is actually the exorcism I got the
answer tape with the church not a shot
now John have to sit in it I don't want
to go near it I don't let anybody do
this do I don't want to touch it no I
don't want to go near it
this is very of anybody this opportunity
but wouldn't it be pulling something you
know something no watching you want to
you you can still see the oil stains
from Ed Warren right here that's holy
oil this is crazy this is crazy that
your students
tis David's mother that is posing with a
chair yes so you got to remember though
these are actual religious statues that
Lorraine Warren gave the Glassell family
during the exorcisms these are their
rosaries from the exorcisms so let me
ask you how long will you sit in that
chair and who will be around you in case
you need medical attention I don't know
I don't know how long I'll sit in it but
I want to give it a try this this this
is an addiction for me it's like when I
find an object like this and I can buy
it and I own it it's like I'm not owning
just the object I'm owning a part of
history in the paranormal world I get
that but I'm owning the curse that's
what I'm saying is there concern that
eventually this curse could catch up to
you yes a hundred percent there is I'm
playing with fire that's what this is
yeah you are
and there gonna be a lot of skeptics out
there that wonder how an object can have
a curse to it but you got to remember
the testimony of documentation that this
chair has you gotta remember what
Lorraine Warren and David and David
Glassell salt
they saw the Beast sitting in this chair
so if you take something that is not
human
it's an entity it doesn't walk the earth
right when that something is using this
object to it easy to to raise to
levitate and all that what does it do to
that chair it forever purses it and I
believe it so I am gonna try to sit in
it but I only want to try to sit in it
to see if I experience that and if I do
develop severe back pain and I do have
to require surgery then that's cool
because it's like I know that this thing
really is cursed like that's that's
magical that's insane I'm this it's cool
right that chair and the people who sold
it to you yeah when you bought it what
did they how did they warn you with that
letter with that letter and they said
that they don't want to have any part of
it do not sit in it you will develop
severe back pain his friend sat in it
and actually had to have surgery and is
still having trouble walking today so
that's all that the information that I
received from directly from the family
hey you know the interesting thing about
Zack is that when you're watching on TV
it's scary but you're in the comfort of
your living room when you're here with
him it is it's terrified it's mind blow
it's a little crazy but I mean it's it's
are you sure you don't want to touch it
are you crazy Charles you were just
mocking it no I'm not now that's even
worse oh my god now I can't
and I'm not trying to make a joke out of
this either you you've mocked that are
you okay
I was not blocking the spirit I was not
my spirit I was not mocking you when we
opened up this exhibit I was I didn't
tell my guides that I was opening it
right and when we opened this up
directly above the chair this is a
flight of stairs and at the top of the
flight of stairs yeah right when I open
this door to open this exhibit a lady
fainted right above which is interesting
but could it be medical where she
dehydrated I don't know but coincidences
all line up after that I had five
different guys that was unaware that I
was opening up this exhibit and five
different guides all began to just cry
uncontrollably and not know why and then
we had another gentleman when this door
opened he was standing here he was
leaning against the wall something was
bothering him and then he collapsed
right here on this little fence thing
right here but it is cool to know that
this object came from such an iconic
case you know Hollywood depicts these
conjuring movies and you know Hollywood
you know they like to you know maybe
sometimes blow it out of proportion a
little bit but the coolest part about
this whole thing is that on Halloween
night
I am reopening a case from Edie and
Lorraine Warren you can see some actual
polaroid photos over there that I took
from the case and that was the original
conjuring that was back in 1973 the
farmhouse in Harrisville Rhode Island
but what a lot of people don't know is
you sit here you're listening to me you
got a rocking chair it's cursed
I believe it's cursed I believe these
things I have other items here that are
cursed and I have witnessed it firsthand
but I feel my back tightening up are you
serious I'm not kidding you right now
I'm not you I'm not my back just started
to that you scared the crap out of me
holy crap I'm gonna stand over here I'm
gonna come outside the room how does the
weirdest thing that's ever happened to
me
[Music]
you okay yeah I just had scared me
alright that just scared the crap out of
me I don't I don't understand that that
is really weirdly spooky okay
is that is that my mind playing tricks
on me if you really feel a physical
sensation in your back then all the
sudden I was like what that butt is
psychosomatic is knowing that there's a
pain associated with an object so you're
looking for that pain right now going to
your brain is not gonna send a signal
for your back to her right but if your
back is truly hurting then something
cool is happening here but what did I
tell you when you mock the chair you
can't do that I wasn't mocking the chair
I was literally I know but what you're
saying is is you went and you said that
you're gonna go touch the chair right
and then you made kind of a joke about
it and I'm being dead serious and not we
would do it or do that to objects like
this and let me tell you something that
chair that has the curse attached to it
are you good yeah yeah I swear to you I
would go ahead that chair that has a
curse to it when they made the movie the
conjuring the first conjuring the
actresses were getting attacked and it
completely freaked them out and they
believed that just making that movie
curse them and the main actress Vera
yeah yeah she got scratches on her in
the same identical scratch pattern
appeared on her laptop screen other
actors and actresses would wake up
between 3:00 and 4:00 every day thinking
that they were being possessed I'm
getting a lot of chills right now and
I'm not it is not cold in here I come
here to do this interview and I was like
good we'll go see this chair and
everything and it'll be you know little
giggles and everything and I feel
tightness in my back well just standing
in proximity to it we're talking about
it I have a lot of energy naturally when
I'm around these objects and it's weird
for me sometimes to be there in front of
the object telling its story with
somebody as well it's you feel it here
but sometimes I don't but I am today let
me ask you this
is there and is there something an
object out there that you really want
that you are searching to get right now
I don't really have one in particular I
let them find me it's kind of a weird
thing I just believe in that I believe
in the spirits and they're out there
they call me on investigations
everything but I want some stuff that's
not known on websites I want to go in
some of those cultures or there's some
things out there that are really bad but
there is one I want okay tell the corpse
of a clown is a real body but somebody
else has it then really jealous about
that but listen I know that you're a
little spooked and that's cool I'm glad
that your backers but there's something
else that I want to show you to kind of
reverse the darkness of this it's a lot
funner I promise all right show me so
there is something contained in a
particular prop and and wolf maybe we'll
open it oh okay okay here we are you
good I'm glad they're back girls I can't
believe it I gladly it's the weirdest
thing okay so recently now I don't
always end drawn to the darkest of dark
the cursed objects things like which I
do have a lot of those I like balance I
have a ton of them but I like balance
and I'm a huge fan ever since I was a
little kid of a particular movie that
has to do with my show goes Avengers of
course what is it
ghostbusters there it is oh wow I love
this hold on how'd you because I take a
break from all the curse stuff I come in
here and I just I get chills but in a
different way like a little boy excited
that I'm actually able to own this stuff
now that's the real deal this is the
real thing it isn't just the real deal
this is the hero ghost trap from
ghostbusters 1 and 2 the hero ghost trap
means that it was
used in all the close-ups all the
special effects scenes and it still
works and this is how they used to
operate it with that remote control you
still got to make it oh though this so
fully works Wow
but now is the question should we
release Slimer let's do it come on now
I'm not afraid of releasing slider so
Egon Spengler yep
now the Harold Remus yep
you know he's yeah he's passed away is
the only Ghostbuster that has passed
away not too long ago there was an
auction in London I was able to get his
actual screen matched jump suit from
ghostbusters to that is his utility belt
that was used in the first Ghostbusters
and I believe in the second as well so
you found the utility belt and added it
to yeah well I got it all in the same
auction okay oh yeah and I also got his
boots and those are heavy boots Harold
had some really big feet and that is
just cool because that's you know if
that's a piece of history I think that
he would liked this you know just a
message to Harold Ramis his family or
his fans I'm just glad that so many
people walk through this door we just
open this exhibit but everybody that
walks through here huge smiles they're
clapping they absolutely love it that's
what this is about it's about preserving
the the iconic ghostbusters and this
here this is actual the backpack right
yeah this is the mold this is the
production mold that they would use to
then make the proton packs how do you
know how did you get that in the same
auction all in the same auction Wow and
Ghostbusters stuff ain't cheap okay so I
was gonna ask you how was the bidding
and how did you jump to the front to get
her because there are museums another
place and just general collectors who
want this battle III it was doing this
online and I just couldn't stop pressing
the bid button I just kept going and
going I didn't really
so all this stuff totaled three hundred
and thirty thousand dollars Wow
and you know what that money is
amazingly spent on items that are
forever iconic in not only cinema but
also the paranormal and they belong here
in the museum forever and by the way
this museum has become one of the
biggest attractions in Vegas so it's a
constant its constant upkeep isn't it it
is it's constant but we are expanding a
little too so you know I got another
building opening up on property but it's
it I love it you know what I mean good
but with me I always say I'm a man of
balance I do have a dark side that's
that's attracted to those things but I
don't worship anything bad and I don't
do anything bad but it's like you bring
a lot of bad things in here but it's the
curiosity and it's the joy to see
somebody be affected by one of my
objects in that you don't experience
that a lot on your interviews no no you
know sir you got some creepy celebrities
you interview but but do you really have
that where you're freaked out that was a
cool moment for me I am really counting
down all the possible things that could
have been wrong was it that I got on a
plane and flew here this morning was it
that I even need to pee because what
made my back hurt at that moment I don't
think having to pee with that hurt I
don't know I'm trying to figure out
something to make sense of it yeah I'll
be honest with you we'll keep portioning
it because that's what happens when
somebody has an experience with the
paranormal but
Vigo's behind you I know he's given you
a dirty look now that is not the
original no Vigo the Carpathian but this
is cool isn't it this is amazing the
fact that you you had you actually have
the working deal back here how often do
you come in here and take it
play with it I just put it in here okay
so we just opened up two days ago but
I'm already wanting to go through this
little door here and start playing with
it again it's like when you're a little
kid and your dad puts a remote-control
car behind glass you later you know I
mean I want to get in there and open it
and play with it and set it out you know
what I mean but this is fictional
Slimers in there the Slimer is in here
so if you want to come see slavery's
these on the trans in there
thank good I needed this kind of like
it's good yes like you had a scary
experience and I let you watch cartoons
I did have a scary experience
you know I've messed me up a little bit
ladies and gentlemen this is it we are
going to walk inside of the house that
inspired the movie the conjuring so
Halloween night we have a two-hour
halloween special on Travel Channel
curse of the Harrisville farmhouse this
is the actual farmhouse that inspired
the conjuring in Rhode Island yes and
you know the parent family they were
there 1973 all of these all of this
activity occurred but what's interesting
is that this legendary iconic
investigation we were able to bring back
an actual family member from the parent
family to help us in the investigation
Andrea Perrin but not only that there's
a lot of things that people don't know
that they you know they saw the movie
the conjuring but there's a lot of
details that you're going to see in our
special that weren't revealed or
disclosed and before ed and Lorraine
Warren responded to this case there were
two other investigators Keith and Carl
Johnson there demonologists now they
join us for this investigation for their
own closure it was like the hand of God
made
fist who's that sighs how scary was it
going into that farkles going in there
as soon as you go into the forum house
you lose track of time and this isn't
just me saying this everybody that went
in there they were lost in space lost in
thought even Andrea Perrin was being
affected the demonologist Keith and Carl
Johnson something happened to Carl that
you will see on Halloween night that
really changed the whole course of the
entire investigation it was disturbing
how do you leave something like that
behind you don't it stays with you
forever
I take a piece of every investigation
with me the difference of this
investigation
it was a long investigation we were
there longer than normal but I was sick
for three weeks after this investigation
like violently ill and it took a lot out
of me and I went in there and I examined
everything with my team but there was
too much evidence that we captured and
that evidence really proved to us that
the current family that's living there
now and they are experiencing things
that told us that whatever was affecting
the parent family is now affecting this
family and that's why we really had
cause to go there trying to help
it was interesting it's a very ancient
entity that is haunting the property in
Harrisville something took two steps at
me lunged at me out of that closet just
now right in front of me
only God is heirs is it one of the most
haunted places absolutely 100%
and people have been trying to
investigate it for years and years and
years so we were given this exclusive
opportunity and it delivered on all
aspects and we didn't know what we were
gonna walk into but just being able to
bring people from the original case that
were inspired the Condry to have them by
our side to investigate with us and see
the effects it had on them and then
wanting to do this foreclosure of what
they experienced back in 1973 it's deep
it's a deep investigation and it took a
piece of me when I left you keep upping
the ante because you know we came here
before we saw the divot box which was
spooky mm-hmm
we didn't open it what's open no no stop
okay okay but now we just did this chair
and this really kind of reached out
affected us on Halloween night you are
going to see me like try to actually sit
in the chair this isn't for a stunt it's
not for anything like that it is crazy
it's because these are my items I
collect them
and to see somebody like it you raise
say that that happens crazy I want to
experience it I mean I want to walk but
I want to experience it are these items
truly cursed I know the Dybbuk boxes I
know some other ones are here but it's a
thrill it's an absolute thrill to have
an object be present during such a
historic iconic case of demonic
possession and along with these
exorcisms that object is made out of
wood it's an earth grown substance that
records that event residually but did
the demon that claimed that chair as its
own did that demon forever put what we
know is this supernatural force called a
curse so that anybody that goes near it
or anybody that mocks it will then feel
the effects of it on being serious I
hear you I hear you
it literally feels like I have been on
my feet for like 24 hours in a pair of
like cart shoes but Jackson you didn't
feel that before
nope I walked it in fine I walk in there
I was fine right and I'm not saying you
mocked it you disrespected it but you
you're like oh my gonna touch it and
then you didn't but I think that moment
could have done some if truly what you
feel and I believe you because I know
you yeah I know
yeah but if you want reverse it commit
it and maybe that will it's up to you no
I always wonder like how do I end up
getting these things yeah and and and
how they all connect together you know I
get the devil's rocking chair
coincidentally Lorraine Warren dies
within hours after I bought it that's a
coincidence but in my field of work
coincidence that means something more to
me right and then now all of a sudden a
house that was closed its doors to any
paranormal investigations for decades
all of a sudden it opens up and hey
revenue The Devil's rocking chair do you
want to investigate this case it's just
things always are lining up in my world
in my paranormal world so when I come
here to the museum I'm bored with
day-to-day life just just getting in
your car going doing a job coming over
all right you come here you feel things
there's a lot of energy here and it's a
it's very mysterious that the powers
that these things have and it's even
cooler to see somebody have a real
experience that bothered you and I get
gratification from that I I swear to you
that's it's real it's real it's real I
will not go in every weekend next
Halloween Kevin I want you to stay in
the museum by yourself
no way overnight no way yourself not to
think about it I'm shocked it I
literally I'm gonna go outside I'm gonna
stretch I'm gonna see like what the
hell's going on my back for real like
I'm
a little nervous about that there is no
I would lose it think about it I don't
have to answer right now think about it
after coming here we talked about this
museum for months right okay and we are
all still a little terrified of coming
but we were all a little afraid to come
back I'm being honest with you and now
to think about staying in here for a
full night by yourself would be and I'm
gonna have different places where you
have to go every hour well put sleeping
bags in every little place it would
break me as a person I'm gonna be honest
with you it would break me is I mean you
would probably see me break I don't
think you would but if you do it would
you know will be everybody will be
watching to see how or why you broke and
then will research the reasons why and
will check the security cameras and see
what happened I think you have a
connection here and I think you should
stay here by yourself for a whole night
next Halloween the invitation is there
[Music]